today we're bringing Kepler 22b into our
planetary neighborhood
where would this planet need to orbit
within the Sun's habitable zone
how would you go visit it
and would you find life when you got
there
this is what if and here's what would
happen if
Kepler-22b was in our solar system
located
635 light years away from Earth
Kepler-22b is the first exoplanet
discovered inside of the habitable zone
of a sun-like star
and that means
Kepler-22b has a chance to be covered
with liquid water
while it's still not known whether it's
Rocky gaseous or liquid
we do know it's pretty big
Kepler-22b is almost two and a half
times larger and about 36 times more
massive than Earth
based on its distance from its own star
in our solar system
Kepler-22b would exist somewhere between
Earth and Venus
and if it orbited there you'd get a
magnificent view of the planet in the
night sky
it would appear about as large as 15
percent of our own full moon
now our sun is slightly bigger and
hotter than kepler-22b's host star
kepler-22 and that increase in
temperature might make it too hot to
host life
also why should Kepler-22b get its own
orbit when it could share ours
what could possibly go wrong with that
if Kepler-22b was to snuggle comfortably
into our orbital path there are only a
few places it would be able to go
those are called LaGrange points
one of those points would be on the
exact opposite side of the Sun from
Earth
but unfortunately that would come with a
few downsides for starters you wouldn't
ever be able to see it that's because it
would always be behind the Sun from our
perspective down here on Earth
but worse than that this location
wouldn't guarantee it a stable orbit
it could get derailed and head directly
toward Earth
and that would be the end of life on
both worlds
who when the two planets were on a
direct Collision Course with each other
better more stable option would be for
Kepler-22b to Nestle into orbit at the
LaGrange points located 60 degrees ahead
and behind Earth
here a third body could maintain a
consistent orbit around the Sun and not
get gravitationally pulled into Earth
then Kepler-22b would have a chance of
Hosting its own life
this planet is about 500 million years
younger than Earth and if it formed in
our Solar System about the same time
Earth did it would have had more than
enough time for various life forms to
evolve
maybe even intelligent ones
think about how amazing it would be to
visit our neighbor and maybe even
establish communication with whoever or
whatever inhabited Kepler-22b
but even with this new Earth 2.0 safely
sharing our habitable spot around the
Sun
getting to it would be a bit of a
challenge
you see our planet is constantly being
pulled toward the Sun by the sun's
enormous gravity
but it's also trying to move straight
into space at the speed of 108 000
kilometers per hour
so if we wanted to visit Kepler-22b we'd
have to manage to counteract that
sideways motion of our planet
otherwise we'd keep moving sideways and
we'd miss our new planetary neighbor
the best thing you could do is swing
around Venus for a little gravity assist
this is a technique that allows your
spacecraft to increase or decrease the
energy of its orbit
in other words you could use Venus to
slow down and arrive at your destination
now all these Maneuvers would require a
lot of fuel and time
the trip to Venus alone would take you
about four months and then you'd have to
apply the gravitational breaks while
approaching Kepler-22b adding even more
time to the journey
but finally you'd arrive and be the
first person ever to see this massive
Earth-like planet up close
and the first thing you'd notice is that
it would be rotating on its side just
like Uranus
this would mean that it's North and
South Poles would either be flooded with
sunlight or shrouded in total darkness
for six months of the year
yeah you've discovered that the climate
might not be as pleasant as you might
have hoped your two options would be
freezing cold or boiling hot
but you shouldn't lose hope there's a
strong possibility you could find that
Kepler-22b is covered in a super ocean
and if it was at least 50 meters deep
this ocean could regulate these
temperature extremes
as you landed you could even find them
within a comfortable range of 15 to 22
degrees Celsius
but that wouldn't be an indicator to
take your spacesuit off just yet
there's still the possibility that 22b
wouldn't have a breathable atmosphere
but no matter what kind of environment
you'd find you'd need to build yourself
a habitat
this would help you maintain air
pressure temperature and the composition
of the air you need to breathe
you could even 3D print this habitat
using the planet's resources
and you'd want to make sure that it
could protect you from radiation just
like our own atmosphere and magnetic
field
right now we don't know all that much
about this not so distant exoplanet but
if Kepler-22b was in our solar system
that would give us plenty of time to
send space probes and study it before
you ever set foot on the surface
as a result of that by the time you
started your mission to Earth 2.0 you'd
already know what kind of temperature
and air this world had
if Kepler-22b was so close to us
settling on it could be easier than
moving to Mars
once you settled on the planet you'd
start desalinating its ocean water and
set up hydro and solar power stations
now food on the other hand would be a
bit tricky
initially growing plants imported from
Earth would require greenhouses with
regulated temperatures and humidity
levels to keep your favorite potatoes
from dying
but as you studied the planet more
outdoor Gardens could become a reality
or you could start developing a taste
for the high protein algae that you
might find growing in the super ocean
and if you're really lucky you could
Discover Life
maybe even an intelligent life
but it doesn't seem likely that you'll
do that because Kepler-22b didn't form
in our solar system if you ever wanted
to land on its alien surface you'd need
to travel hundreds of light years and be
prepared to overcome a long list of
obstacles
but okay so what if you did travel all
the way to Kepler 22b
well that's a story
for another
what if